what is the force that causes objects to
fall to the ground
girl you better I know this because my
titties are low thanks to gravity yay a
personal anecdote can we just also say
we don't actually need gravity but
that's a different thing I saw something
we were watching something where
someone's like we don't actually need
gravity we're watching this to me like
we actually don't need it what do you
mean that we don't need gravity what if
it was never invented
invented by who
Sir Isaac Newton
Isaac Newton created gravity
whoever created gravity someone did but
we don't actually need it there was a
time on Earth before gravity existed yes
who who created gravity babe
Dan it was Isaac Newton you're right
you were in the right ballpark Sir Isaac
Newton perhaps first defined and
discovered what do you mean we don't
need gravity I'm curious about that we
just don't need it but like what do you
mean the moon doesn't have gravity
oh boy it does all bodies all Celestial
I mean all body gravity anything with
that has gravity in fact some would say
you have a sizable amount of gravity
what's that mean
I'm fat you're calling me fat yeah
attractive thank you Moses
well you're fat
um we've got quite a large pay dispute
happening with our Australian women's
soccer team at the moment
um is it frustrating for you as someone
who's so prominent in your sport
and we heard you say on The Ellen Show
the other day you are the richest
fighter in UFC that that sort of thing
is still going on
I think that how much you get paid
should have something to do with how
much money you bring in I'm the highest
paid fighter not because Dana and
Lorenzo wanted to do something nice to
the ladies
they do it because I bring in the
highest numbers they do it because I
make them the most money and I think
that the money that she they make should
be proportionate to the money that they
bring in because that's all guys want
all you guys want to see I swear to God
what no no let me rephrase that
Diddy men
want to see and that's all they want
from you higher guys that are worth more
that will benefit your life more they're
not just going to want to see from you
and that's a fact or could it be that
the men that only want sex from women is
because that's all that the women have
to offer
because for me it sees all you're
offering sees all I want
yeah
just like you know what how many times
you've gotten to a club into VIP for
free when some ugly chicks had to pay
full price
is that my fault no no no I've asked how
many times did it happen before you go
down that path I mean plenty of times in
Miami exactly but that's not fair is it
well please don't forget I'm not from
here but that's not the point ma'am
that's not fair is it I also don't care
about those things but oh so you only
care about fairness when it when it
doesn't benefit you I just don't go to
clubs that often but that's not the
point I asked you how many times you've
gone to a close well you got any free
with ugly chicks or less attractive
chicks had to pay and you know that's
happened you didn't say I'm still excuse
me sir uh even though I'm attractive I
demand that you charge me full price
you're okay with the double standards
that benefit you but the ones you don't
like you just throw at the wind use sign
language shame insults guilt and the
need to be right to deflect and dismiss
guys who are normally intimidated by
this thing I'm not I'm just challenging
your position okay with it not being
fair when it benefits you Michael do you
know what the leading cause of death for
pregnant people is pregnant people
mothers women if you'd like to call them
mothers not all of them are mothers if
you'd like to call them that what are
they if they're not mothers they're
pregnant people what what people other
than mothers are pregnant
does it bother you to use inclusive
language it's just interesting I prefer
to use precise language it's interesting
because you come into this conversation
you know trying to hold this moral
superiority but then when I
will when I can but right but when I use
inclusive language which it only takes a
couple extra syllables to use inclusive
language it seems to include people who
don't clap you know identify as women
but can become pregnant so
like a person who's born a woman and
then identifies as a man and is pregnant
yeah so you're telling me that in order
to be a moral person I need to accept
the idea that a man
someone who was born a man who looks
like a man can really become a woman
that's that's a prerequisite of my being
a moral person
I mean yes to me it is because if you
are trying to deny someone of their
identity and deny what their life
experience is then that doesn't seem
like a moral stance to me I want to be
accepting and I want to respect people's
life experiences and respect the way
that they want to identify and respect
the way that they want to present
themselves to the world I would like to
identify I do identify actually as the
correct person on this issue of abortion
I identify as being correct and more
correct than you on this issue and I
would just ask that you accept and
affirm my identity
all right
do you well you are not a medical
professional an abortion and pregnancy
that's not your identity that is my I
promise you that's my identity you don't
want to get married at all you don't
want a family children yes but in the
future but no no you're 28 right yes uh
well how when do you want to have kids
35 maybe well at 35 90.
um from a biological standpoint at 35
years old over around 90 of your eggs
are gone and your ability to bring a
child to term comes down a lot
I don't think so well
I mean we can say you can say you don't
think so but realistically speaking your
chances of having a child bringing these
three eggs at 35. that doesn't work
often and it's very expensive
I don't know I want to enjoy my life so
I'm not ready
[Music]
is that for teenage boys now they are so
terrified of the consequences of putting
a foot out of line it was hard enough
being a young teenager working out how
things are working out how to do dating
and all of that without the terror that
if you touch in the wrong place at the
wrong time you may find that your whole
life is destroyed too much well I I like
that my mother of a teenage boy
I think that men should be frightened I
think you feel better
but we're talking about yeah
an interesting thing that you see I
would say that that attitude actually is
part of the problem too that is top
that's to me toxic femininity that is
saying you should all be terrified you
men if you put one assaulting well I I I
think we all understand what sexuality
what Isabelle's talking about is that
young teenage clumsiness in many cases
which is now being re-categorized as a
sword is that a problem not being
re-categorized as a soul it's always
been assault it's just we're finally
talking about I don't agree with that
but I do think it's really hard for a 16
17 year old boy now in this environment
to know even how to start they are all
having some kind of physical
relationship with a woman those good
boys are all terrified I know that from
talking to my son he's just like I'm
just not going there is that healthy yes
I think it is actually I think it's
better to not have a physical
relationship than to have one that could
ruin a woman's life but then how do they
ever start well don't if you're not 100
sure we're gonna have a bunch of Newton
Boys we actually do have that gen Z is
having for Less sexual relationships
and I'm also interested I mean like
George and I look at the data and I look
at the studies and I'm really also very
much interested in studies like the
analysis that was done by the American
Psychological society which looked at 45
analysis of whether there's sex
difference over 20 years and its
conclusion was that men and women are
basically alike in terms of personality
in terms of cognitive ability in terms
of leadership but what it did find was
that media depictions of men and women
as fundamentally different perpetuate
misconceptions as does workplace fine oh
God so it's my fault so no well you know
you're leaving soon men and women men
and women actually are more the same
than they are different but the issue is
is that small differences at the
population level can turn into very
large differences at the extreme so for
example men and women are broadly
similar with regards to aggression
although men tilt a little bit more
towards aggression about so that if you
pick the random person out of the
population male and female and you
guessed that the male was more
aggressive you'd be right 60 of the time
but if you take the one in a hundred
most aggressive people they're all male
and that's why the overwhelming
proportion of people who are in prisons
are male now do you want to equalize
that just out of curiosity what about
bricklayers there are 99 male and if and
we've got about three quarters of of the
population now in universities in the
humanities and social sciences are
female are we going to equalize that and
men men work more longer hours they work
more dangerous jobs they're more likely
to move they're more likely to work
outside they're more likely to
participate in jobs in the stem fields
that are scalable they make more money
for those reasons and that's all hidden
under the idea that the reason that men
and women make different amounts of
money is because of their gen